happy Friday rejects how are you doing
John how are you yeah that's good it's
good YouTube energy to have great I'm
amazing we're gonna watch the difference
between Australia and New Zealand
this is requested patron video request
from Austin Harris and one of our war
tears with everybody at your request we
must definitely do and rare is the day
where they asked us to do a video that
is currently relevant to our times or
with the channel is all about but hey
it's one of the reward tears right okay
let's check this out this is from a
channel out of dad mmm-hmm he looks like
me but buffer and better looking
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
I knew I could go on forever but you
know that would be he's definitely got
the the taiko ytt and flight of the
conchords sense of humor though dry
delivery that must be I was I was like
British wit and sarcasm that must be
like that or New Zealand wit and yeah
there's a New Zealand wit and sarcasm
that's kind of like this fumbling way of
talking yeah it's very affable very and
tripping over your words a little bit
yeah a little nervous a little kind of
like a Ricky Gervais spot for New
Zealand 20 I just saw Lord in concert a
couple weeks ago
very very New Zealand Lee we we were
late now what we connect to the video as
you saw Lord in concert well I had a key
we boss for a couple years so like so
you can pick up this is the differences
I was like he's probably from New
Zealand the second he switched in the
Australian I was like yep like I don't
know like the the finest points but I do
know some of the annunciation things and
some of the slang and stuff I can't
quite pinpoint it but I can usually tell
I don't really know exactly what it is
like where do you start talking like oh
it's probably New Zealand her and I
rarely get them mixed up but I don't
know I just kind of trust my instincts
on it there are some fascinating
differences here
you like Australians a bit sharper for
whatever reason fish was always a token
that was used for me whereas Australia
its fish and New Zealand it's fish okay
yeah something about that kind of helps
to encapsulate speeches I feel like New
Zealand ever since Lord of the Rings has
been getting a lot more popular getting
a lot more attention
hmm opening up the door before you know
it more people
traveling people already started
traveling there because of the Lord of
the Rings and was the Shire town or
something like that the shine the Shire
on the Shire town I mean there are towns
within the Shire I'm sure yeah yeah Tyco
ytt yeah that's all I really know about
New Zealand few things you actually just
told me right here it's a funny video
because I was give me some actual like
educational video like the major
differences between New Zealand and
Australia it's just like putting like
the tiniest things that I'm probably
gonna forget I hope though that this
inspires people to come to our patreon
and just request education ten minutes
worth of history at a time you know just
watch us learn on the air who is this
guy he's a funny guy
subscribe he's smart because he's
wearing a big shirt and he's clearly a
buff guy because if he just shows off
the muscles it just won't be that funny
might not be as related won't be as
relatable this is all about like a to be
a dad these guys earned himself a
subscription button Oh body boom this is
the kind of videos I'll watch on my own
yeah check in it yeah just for myself
give yourself a little dose of joy in
your day yeah this seems like a
delightful do to watch he's very
friendly
well thanks Austin Harris for your
unique requests and thank you for
introducing us to a channel Austin I
know you had a surgery recently and I'm
glad to hear you're recovering well my
friend and we're actually gonna hop on a
Google hangout with you in a little bit
this video is coming to you from the
future that you'll see it in the feel
see it in the future and our hangout
will be the Oreo cream at the center of
all of this yeah I just hope you're not
mean to us in our hangout because I
would like to included it in here yeah
I'm gonna secretly record our hangout so
be careful what you say buddy and you're
not gonna have any actual heads-up about
this I'm recording the entire thing so
any naughty joke or racist thing you say
whether
firm again Connecticut Ohio someplace
where racism is just right so so
deserted State get ready you get to work
on that Austin could you get to work on
curing racism in your hometown while
you're recovering you're gonna be
receiving a huge internet backlash and I
upload and expose who you are but thanks
for being a part of the patreon and
we're lucky to have you buddy
hey you can subscribe to the real
rejects and yeah there's videos them